it in that perspective it's been three
months you've been seeing this girl
she's beautiful your friends think yo
how have you got this girl she's
absolutely stunning she's career driven
she's ambitious she's everything that
you value in a girl but then she looks
to say do you know what yo like I've
it's double digits I've slept with 20
people are you then gonna say
don't do it
I'm getting hot or play a part are you
then gonna say to her you could be the
love of my life but sorry you've slept
with 20 men let me know explain are you
going to do that yeah it's a great
scenario it's a great scenario I respect
what you're saying but Joseph would not
let it get to three months for asking
that question and the love of my life
could never